we got some chilling updates from Andrew
Tate in his prison cell let's check
these out they're trying to break me
thrown inside a cell without light
cockroaches lice and bed bugs are my
only friends at night when the guards
bring me to and from the courtroom I
stay absolutely respectful they try to
pour hatred into my heart but please and
thank you stick with me at all times my
prison guards are just performing their
job and they have families to feed in
times of hardship do not forget your
manners they are just trying to break my
iron mind with unjust imprisonment my
absolute respect for everyone around me
is an act of absolute Rebellion they
cannot break me my guards know I'm
innocent they know it is unjust that's
that's crazy rule
cockroaches bro you know it's been a
long time since he's been used to that
environment I know his woman who who got
falsely in prison and he had a very
similar experience where
uh when he was in his cell
um not that there was no light but it
was pretty much like roaches and stuff
like this
because it was in uh it was in a third
world country
so
vanilla preserving may Allah Graham's
strength male uh get him out of there as
soon as possible and
um
yeah just keep it from any evil and any
false accusations at the end of this
whole thing I mean see the thing is bro
I agree with you and for all before a
lot of the people come out of their
throat in the comments for all we know
till today he's a Muslim brother his
brother in Islam there's no evidence
against him for these accusations so of
course we're going to go based off of
the presupposition that he's gonna until
proven guilty right but if there is
obviously okay cool that'll change
things but for now we still have hope
for him and we still make door for him
for Allah to make it easy for him and
for him to come out inshallah so lay it
up it is definitely a slippery slope as
someone who's kind of looked at both
sides
um it is difficult
and I want to clear something up since
we're on the topic I want to clear
something up
um the reason I say it's difficult is
because
human trafficking isn't just like you
know let me pick up this person and ship
them off to you know some random country
in the you know in the East or something
human human trafficking by like
including Romanian law is just it could
include basically coercing people and
tricking them into working for you to do
you know sexual acts and that stuff
um in in any capacity now the thing
about Andrew's case is because he had a
webcam business
it um
may be difficult to prove or disprove if
there was force of coercion involved and
that's the only reason this whole thing
is tricky and I think that's the only
um
you know evidence they have against them
is this something where he was actually
forcing and coercing women were they
there on their own volition do they have
the ability to leave and something that
I think is is tremendously flawed in
Western thinking nowadays is on one hand
they say women are so you know empowered
liberated and they're as strong as men
they can compete in Men in any Avenue in
life
but when it comes to this field
specifically they're so gullible that
they could be deceived and tricked into
working you know for a man to do sexual
acts and not even know that they're
basically being controlled in this way
force is one thing threats is one thing
but if they love the guy and work for
him then 10 years later are basically
told you didn't really love him you were
just feeling that you were actually
being forced and they then they believe
it you know that's a very gray area
so no one really knows what happened but
you know as it is an Islamic premise
it's also a western premise that
innocent until proven guilty if there is
no evidence you cannot say he is guilty
and until there's evidence uh you cannot
say that he is 100 guilty
um so let's just make Dua for the
brother inshallah that Allah preserves
him
and um that we know you know the truth
at the end of inshallah and that if he
is innocent that he is freed without any
false you know accusations or fines or
imprisonment or anything else he's
already been detained for you know 30
days they want to bring him for keep him
for another 30 days subhanallah you know
because in the first day they found no
evidence so it's very very saddening
I mean bro I mean
how exactly
are we getting updates from him
if he's imprisoned they apparently let
him receive send emails to uh fans or
something like that
and also there's someone on the outside
doing a lot of these tweets too even
though this one was obviously him
um because there's some about past
things the new world promotions you know
stuff like that so there's no way he's
doing that right now
yeah but I agree with brother Romney
bless you Brothers for bringing that
Nuance point up because in today's
modern time we are living in a parable
the parable of Parables of modern
feminism bro where people think that
they can be independent and strong and
and I don't need no man but up until the
point where
it's not in their favor anymore and then
at that point now it's it's the man's
fault for everything you get what I mean
yeah at the end of the day we as men
need to teach our men folk to understand
the responsibilities and islamically how
we should behave with women things that
we are not allowed to do whatsoever and
then with women we also simultaneously
we can't just defuse all the
responsibility from them at all we need
to tell them where not to go What Not to
Wear who not to hang around with what
time to not leave the house and I think
if you guys think that's controlling or
misogynistic then be my guest do that
and see what happens to them because
when it's said and done and they leave
the house when next to nothing in the
middle of the night and something
happens to them
you can't say that it's the guy's fault
all the time 100 percent
sure is it is does it justify what he
did no of course not but why was she out
there alone why is she going to a hotel
room to meet a guy by herself like what
is going on there you know what I mean
yeah uh just to be clear obviously
um the first perpetrator and the person
who should be punished right because
being a punishment is whoever the man is
in that situation if a man you know
harms a woman in any way that person is
you know uh penalized and Islam very
very harshly by the way there's more way
more harsh than Western Law so we're not
you know against any of those points but
there is it's I think fallacious and and
stupid frankly to say that there is no
fault on on on the person for putting
themselves in such a stupid situation if
I um I'm gonna be honest if I put myself
in a stupid situation actually I have
done this before and Fiat is witness to
this I've done I put myself in a dumb
situation uh where I I basically got
robbed it wasn't a lot but a little bit
of crypto because I was I was stupid I
was I was Dumb and I made a dumb mistake
I lost my money but I own that you know
that's my fault uh you know I was mad at
the person who did it obviously but I
was the dummy that that put myself in
that situation by not being cautious and
giving things away that I shouldn't have
right uh so in the case that a person
goes in a sketchy area at a sketchy time
or wearing something that if somebody is
gonna commit this crime would be more
likely to commit that crime against you
especially if you're alone that's just
not wise you know wisdom is putting
something where it belongs and a woman
does not belong half naked in the middle
of the street in a sketchy corner at
night
um so that's what I'm trying to say with
that and at the end of the day bro I
want to be on record here very clearly
bro we've said this many times we as men
have failed we have men fulfilled the
civilization we have lost sight of our
responsibilities and Authority as men
with that power sure it's power but
there's responsibility there's
accountability in the eyes of Allah we
should have been there we should have
had krita we should have put our foot
down we should have maintained the level
of masculinity that Allah wants us to
maintain without it being anything over
or anything deviant from Quran and
Sunnah and we failed that bro look at
Muslim families today daughters are just
doing whatever and I feel like at the
end of the day
if we haven't failed I don't think women
would have been to the extent where they
are today because it's reactionary it's
um I was oppressed in my thing or my dad
didn't do anything so now I'm doing this
it's it's almost like an ego thing to
get even
and I think that if you have one extreme
it's going to birth another extreme so
if you're a woman or sister watching
this and you've been not in the best
upbringing you got the show and the
stake islamically speaking from your
father or from your men Folk
you trying to now reactively
be rebellious that's not going to
produce anything good
and the vice versa if you're a man if
you were taught incorrectly improper
masculinity saying oh I don't know any
better and I could just carry this on
that's not right either so there comes a
point in our life when we need to take
these things into our own hands and no
longer blame okay this is my upbringing
this is society I live in the west or
whatever and we should take it upon our
own selves to pray for to Allah to
guidance to help us have these traits
that make us proper Believers in Islam
on hole
oh no's looking very cold I have an open
heart because the things beautifully and
if I started speaking too much I'm gonna
start coughing so
far everyone make Dua for a brother
Angel that's Allah grants him shifa and
a speedy recovery I mean
I mean
and with that being said
foreign